[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we got a high
quality teaser to break down for
Avengers 4 let's get to it we're doing a
new round of that spider-man ps4
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video rewind a little while ago this
summer you may remember we got a look at
a scene where they're all flying across
frame together like they did during age
of Ultron and it's meant to be this oh
wow moment even Iron Man and Captain
America are together in frame like when
Captain America was leading the charge
with black panther during the battle of
Wakanda
we have ant-man over here fresh out of
the quantum realm and Captain Marvel in
her new version of the costume fully
powered up just all ready to go probably
one of the biggest changes here is
Professor Hulk not quite as big as he is
when he's full green monster but looking
in full command of his abilities because
he looks more focused and he's wearing a
suit of armor that looks like it scales
up as he grows bigger so that he doesn't
shred a pair of pants every single time
he hooks out we even got Hawkeye Ronan
down here in the bottom even if they
just call him Hawkeye during the movie
the reason why we're referring to him as
Ronan is because of the persona the
attitude the personality change from the
previous movies that's why we call
Captain America nomad even though during
infinity war everyone still called him
cap during the movie he's not Captain
America anymore he's left that persona
behind he's more like the Nomad
character so that's why we refer to
Hawkeye as Ronan but when that came out
a lot of people wondered if it was fake
because nobody knew where it had come
from like people were trying to pick out
things in the background this is really
just meant to be a star-filled like
there's nothing behind them here this is
just meant to be a battle on what looks
like the remains of a planet similar to
Titan like you just look at these jagged
edges here in the rocks they look very
similar to the terrain of Titan even
though the colors a little bit wrong and
then another concept art there was
Thanos with a giant sword his armor was
back on he was still wearing the
Infinity Gauntlet and it had been
repaired but remember this was meant to
be concept mock-ups of a big scene that
they were working on for special effects
so we need that can change a little bit
in post-production but a lot of people
just felt like this was something that
we weren't gonna see during the movie
until we got a look at the reshoots that
they're doing behind the scenes so
within that you have Black Widow with
longer hair that's like a bit red and
at the same time which looks exactly
like her hair in this concept art here
we have cap with no beard I think we all
assumed that he was gonna go back to
looking like regular cap even if his
costume was going to change we have an
ant-man and then there was a
motion-capture person that we're not
totally sure who it is but ain't me and
obviously it was coming out of the
quantum realm anyway so he was going to
join up with them but there was a big
question about when that scene was
happening but it does seem to confirm
some of the authenticity of what's going
on in this image here in terms of
costume and style change the funny thing
about black widows hair though is that
you can kind of use that hair growth in
the way the dye has changed in her hair
to chart the timeline so unless she's
been read eyeing it and cutting it over
a period of a couple of years it doesn't
seem like this scene with Ant Man
Captain America and Widow is more than
say a couple months after what happens
during infinity war like much later in
the year but not many many years down
the road like look at her hair here
during the battle of Wakanda pretty
short she's been pretty short-haired
except for Iron Man 2 when she had this
really long red curls pretty much since
that first Avengers film and every time
she's popped up her hair's been pretty
short but it's super long again now and
what happened is is leading up to
Infinity Ward the Russos explained that
because it was the Secret Avengers and
they were all fugitives they all had to
change their appearance just a little
bit so that they weren't immediately
recognizable as those people although
even with the beard you had probably
Spock Captain America pretty easily like
oh hey isn't that Captain America with a
huge beard isn't he a war criminal or
something right now Thank You captain
pretty sure this guy's a war criminal
now but whatever after Saudis video
described out of state let's do it so as
part of that the ruse was explained that
they wanted Black Widow to dye her hair
blonde to just denote a big change in
her personality in that her
circumstances had changed a lot like
I've been through a lot of [ __ ] like
even Captain America's costume is all
torn up and frayed which I'll talk about
in a second because that gets into the
scale armor that we see during this high
quality concept art now confirm the
Ronan costume is just meant to be
stealth gear like if you look at the age
of Ultron costume he's still got some of
the purple highlights but he's slowly
getting darker and darker and more
practical but now that he's on the run
hunting what seems like Scrolls based on
the descriptions that we've heard he's
just wearing his full
Ronen armor because i mean it's
basically ninja armor meant to be super
stealth couple of the characters still
look like they haven't had any real
significant costume upgrades or changes
i've already talked about why that's
important for Iron Man's character art
because even though they come together
as heroes as full-blown Avengers in this
scene here most of the movie is him
still being broken by spider-man's death
and everything that's happened so he
just hasn't gotten past that emotionally
and it sort of put a technological
writer's block so to speak on him he
just hasn't been able to innovate or do
anything that he would normally be doing
no real significant costume upgrades for
Thor that we can see maybe he washed
that eye out that rocket gave him I hope
that he washed that no real significant
change to Rockets appearance that's not
a big surprise the big thing that they
upgraded with him movie to movie is
typically the weapons that he works with
hopefully sure he will help him out with
that if he doesn't go back to the
dormant space Forge we all kind of knew
the cap was gonna get a scale armor
eventually but most of you noticed the
easter egg in previous movies like
especially infinity war when you see it
really up close is the same armor from
Civil War he's been wearing this whole
time except he's darkened the star
because he's not Captain America anymore
and he doesn't want to be quite as
identifiable it's more of a stealth
version of the costume but he's painted
over some of the aspects and it's just
gotten dirty with where like it's just
literally been wearing it this whole
time so it's just been breaking down
slowly you look up really close though
and underneath this top layer you see
the scales so it just sounds like they
tuned this a little bit shiny it up and
it's the same basic costume albeit with
exposed scales just like the comics for
those of you asking about his upgraded
shield that they mentioned during
spider-man homecoming yes Tony does have
upgrades that are ready for a cap he was
probably planning for this to happen at
some point like he knew he eventually
needed to make good with cap but he just
wasn't ready yet as of the beginning of
infinity war but who cares about that
now because half of all life is dead so
there are just a couple different
versions of caps shield that he could
potentially get we haven't seen any
official mock-ups for it other than I'm
expecting it to look like the classic
shield albeit with some tech upgrades so
either Iron Man has incorporated his
nanotech armor in vibranium to make a
version of the energy
shield that's like a physical shield
that forms out of his gauntlet and his
vibranium and looks like the classic
shield and then he could just make it go
away when he wants to or it's literally
just a physical shield that he cares
around and puts on his back like he used
to
I think the reasoning being giving him a
new shield is the fact that they
scratched up so bad during civil war and
it's sort of representative of all the
conflict they had before shield doesn't
belong to you you don't deserve it
Tony walking that back and telling cap
that he does deserve it is them saying
that that's all water under the bridge
get that man a shield it really does
look like Hulk got some vibranium
upgrades to his costume here because I
mean I suppose there's fabric that Iron
Man could create that would expand with
Hulk as he gets bigger but you have to
imagine that all the clothing that they
wear in Wakanda at least on a certain
level the elite characters is all made
from vibranium weave but I don't think
that they've incorporated any of that
special kinetic energy absorption that
they have - Black Panthers costume it
would be hilariously redundant if you
wore armor that absorb damage as far as
footage and trailers that are dropping
as far as I know the Captain Marvel
trailer is supposed to drop sometime
late in October if we get any new
information that says otherwise I will
totally do a video about it New York
Comic Con is coming up in a couple weeks
we're supposed to get the Avengers for
title after we get the Captain Marvel
trailer though I'll name a new giveaway
winner when I post new marble click here
for that Avengers for plot synopsis the
Kevin Feige gave us and click here to
watch the spider-man ps4 post credits
scene again thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]